so yeah so i guess it followed that
would be
uh do you think that um
so so you'd be in
maybe you've already answered this and
that and i just miss it so you would be
okay with uh platforming these terrible
uh opinions right so long as they're
being
pushed back again so long as yes someone
is equipped to challenge them when they
come up so my my overall view is if
there's some
value in my audience
knowing that these views exist and i
feel equipped to rebut them
then i'm open to doing it basically
that's my video okay yeah
okay thank you okay so next question is
going to be from a giga gigger cope
free speech extremists by the way um
what are the chances that aoc will run
for president and how fruitful do you
think this would be
uh i have no idea whether she plans to
run for president and i think how
fruitful it will be depends on when she
does it i mean i think if she did it i i
guess she would just barely squeak in in
terms of being old enough by a few
months in 2024 and i think it wouldn't
go well i think she'd have no shot
whatsoever i think in the future you
know who knows uh it's
we're you know we're just humans are not
very good at making these type of
predictions and i think uh in the future
it's possible that she could have a real
shot or that she kind of
evaporates and fades away and goes uh
into doing something else but i think in
24 if she ran she would have no shot
okay
uh next question is going to be from
autonomy autonomy whenever you're ready
oh
yes what's going on pregnant um long
time here um so
there is um like a a common sentiment in
the black community that black people
who are like politically inert and that
the right wing and the left wing are two
two sides of the same bird
um so what is like a measure of progress
that we can point to easily that is like
either from democrats or you know like a
progressive policy that helps black
people that we can point to
you're saying over over what period of
time i guess are you saying
uh recently recently
well i mean recently trump's been
president for four years so i think i'm
trying to let me see if i the best way i
can kind of answer this i mean i i think
there's a wh
i would kind of say put it in a
different way i would ask folks what
matters to them okay what how do you
evaluate how a community is doing and
then i would take their lead in
diving deeper on that so to speak so if
they say well you know i i'm concerned
with
what are the average uh wages of black
folks for example you know and then i
would go and i would find the wage data
and i would say look here here's here's
the period of time over we which we can
observe this and you can look at how
wages have gone up and you can tie it to
increases to the minimum wage and you
can tie it to different social programs
regarding economic mobility geographic
mobility etc it's tough to answer the
question in a vacuum because it's so
broad
um but usually when folks want to have
conversations with me like that i say to
them i put it on them to tell me how
would you measure improvement or
worsening and then kind of take it from
there if that makes sense
that makes perfect sense thank you my
pleasure
okay thanks autonomy
and next question is going to be from uh
kaka kafecko is his name i'll bear
admitted whenever you're ready mr
hello
yes sir
all right
[Applause]
um so i have a quick question let me
just find it right over here sorry for
the dogs in the background
yeah so whatever happens guys i'm sorry
it's a you you sound like you're
underwater and echoing and there's a dog
in the background i it's just sounding
like just one long word to me
yeah
um circle perfume oh my god please and
thank you
okay wait hold on was that you that was
me again yes oh you sound much better
now okay all right sorry about that uh
all right scratch that all over again so
a long time first time you missed my
spanish speaking capabilities but all
right whatever my pleasure what happened
to the uh to your spanish show i've
i was following it for a little bit fell
off and uh
and yeah just uh explained to us
what what went on oh it was a 13-week um
show just based around the election
basically from from about a month before
the 2020 election through the
inauguration it was designed to be kind
of like a temporary thing
and uh we we did it we it ended we
finished it
okay so what was your take away from it
you being you know primarily a uh an
english speaker trying to transition
into like you know the spanish speaking
kind of audience
my biggest surprise was the degree to
which
conspiracy theories and disinformation
targeted to the latino community yes
successfully have invaded the latino
community i mean
the amount of spanish language
conspiracy theories and weird emails
that i started getting when i did the
spanish show it was genuinely depressing
no yeah definitely you know i'm i'm a
mexican descent and i'm going to get to
that in just a sec yeah i'm from mexican
descent and uh my parents are very much
into like uh into the president of the
current president andres mandoldo
if you go to like these uh these like uh
i i don't want to say that word but i
just say the fanatic sort of videos like
you'll see a lot of like pro russian
propaganda pro you know like assad
propaganda things of that sort so you
hit the nail right on the head
on that now getting back to
the mexico thing
whatever happened to pedro man
i don't know we haven't he hasn't called
in for a while you know i i don't know
where he is i would love for him to call
back in yeah you know what because he
said he was from colombia and i i always
wanted to tell you this
he actually you know it could possibly
be that he is from colombia but in
mexico so if you go on the map or on
google maps and you and you search for
colombia
there will be a colombia that's right
next to the texas border so this is a
little fun thing i found i was just kind
of like messing around online and yeah
we'll look for him we'll see if we can
find him
yeah well anyway man mucho gusto i hope
everything's going well with you and uh
take care thank you so much
thank you okay next question is going to
be from megwine meg whenever you're
ready
hi david um
so my question is uh why
why is the left so bad at organizing
compared to the right or i guess why is
the rate so much better at organizing
like with cpac and everything and more
importantly how do we get better at it
yeah i mean i i unfortunately a lot of
it is just money i mean the right pours
money into getting people on campus
getting people as soon as they graduate
organizations like turning point usa
they fund tons of media training for
right wing right wingers
um and the left just doesn't do it and i
i've seen this before i i don't think
it's that there is no money
i think it's just not invested in this
type of thing and people will say well
soros soros soros is one guy you know
and he's not really doing what what the
right is doing um but the the it's it's
mostly just having the money
and the determination to do it and it's
very depressing because if the left did
what the right does
and we had an equivalent to cpac and an
equivalent to all of these organizations
that are really well funded and
proactive the left would be doing much
much better
yeah um if only we had someone on the
left who has you know quite a following
and uh could mobilize people
yeah well i mean there are people but
it's just you know that you can only do
so much without millions and millions of
dollars being poured in specifically to
build these movements
yeah well thank you david my pleasure
thank you
uh next up is froggy
froggy whenever you're ready mister
uh hello
hello
uh so
i just wanted to ask
like i personally i watch hakeem and i i
saw a video where he said that like
communism doesn't work and i just felt
that the arguments you gave weren't
that well
so uh could you like explain more on why
you believe communism doesn't work
sorry what the arguments weren't that
well what or who where did you see this
who's hakeem
it's it's never mind i just all right
yeah
can you just tell me like why you think
communism doesn't work that well
um oh man uh i i i i don't know that my
arguments have ever been that communism
doesn't work that well
i've argued why i've explained why i'm
not a communist and there's a number of
different
reasons like
that like that's like a personal opinion
that doesn't really matter to me i just
won't really kind of know why you think
it'd
work i i i'm not a guy who goes around
talking about it doesn't work that well
i i just i'm just not a
communist oh do you i mean
i guess the question would be
where has it worked well i'm curiou you
tell me
i mean i personally believe that the
ussr was like it's pretty good i mean
they had one percent
one to two percent uh unemployment they
nearly eradicated homelessness by uh
giving free housing
they pretty much won the space race
especially from the feudal backwater of
europe to a superpower
so i mean i would say the ussr was
pretty good
uh okay i've never heard anyone make
that argument before but that's that's
interesting um why do you think it
ultimately failed
uh
um
i mean you probably heard this before i
just think it was uh due to gorbachev
just because
uh i i wouldn't say it was his economic
reforms that killed the ussr it was more
uh
oh i believe it's more of a social
reforms i mean he would let like pretty
much liberals uh come in the office and
just ruin it
yeah i mean i don't know from from
everything i've read about the ussr uh
yeah i mean i guess there's a question
as to how you want to measure well-being
and this is a tough thing to do
um but in in terms of
you know
per capita gdp i think the ussr never
even got to a third of per capita gdp
in wealthy you know northern european
countries so so that's one metric that's
at least a starting point to look at but
um i mean it's it's an interesting
question i mean i'm i'm willing to have
my mind changed on anything but i'm not
hearing anything super compelling
uh
by the way like ussr gdp for capital was
like i believe like 10 000 in 1990
so i don't know what it wasn't for like
norway or some somewhere like that in
1990 okay yeah i have no idea if you're
talking about ppp adjusted dollars or
inflation adjusted over i you know i
just don't have the data in front of me
but yeah i mean i would i i'm i've not
done videos about communism doesn't work
so i just am not it's just not my
argument to have you know
oh yeah okay i'm just not a communist
that's understandable
thank you thank you froggy my pleasure
uh next question is from evan not kevin
uh the question is has your opinion
changed on the written house case
in in what sense
changed since when
i i guess at all so or maybe maybe this
will be easier what is your current
opinion on the written house case okay
my opinion is that uh the kyle
rittenhouse case
is a shining example
of so much of what is wrong with the
united states
i believe it's a failure in parenting
it's a failure in education
it's a failure in gun culture
and a failure of common sense
and i believe that
per the law
it makes sense that written house was
found not guilty by reason of
self-defense
because as the laws are written
um
it seems in line with the facts of the
case
okay uh and i guess there's a follow-up
to that one we have a question from
ranger here ranger one of you ready hey
davis what's up thank you welcome
yeah i wanted to ask your stance on gun
control specifically because personally
i'm a big
i'm a big believer that the united
states if it were to disarm it would be
a mistake
because essentially the government would
be taking guns away from people who
might need them to protect themselves
like say hypothetically i'm a trans
woman in a southern state and there's a
risk of me being you know potentially
attacked and killed for a hate crime
yeah i personally believe that if i'm
under threat from lethal force i should
be able to have a weapon of equivalent
or greater force to stop that threat to
protect myself
right in other words you you don't you
don't want only the right wing nuts
having the guns it sounds like
yeah basically that's my position on it
anything and i think it would if the
left were to agree to this army it would
very much head in that direction
so i think that um
so the the term disarm is a little bit
loaded i mean i think here's here's the
framework that i'm operating under
um there's a second amendment in the
united states and that's not going to
change anytime soon full stop given that
there is a second amendment in the
united states we then can ask the
question
do democrats tend to do well when they
prioritize gun safety legislation or not
well at the local level and generally
speaking it tends to not be a smart
thing for democrats to run on at the
local level because they're called gun
grabbers and it seems to motivate
republicans to come out and vote against
them much more than it motivates
democrats to
come out and vote for them now that
being said
my opinion about
gun safety regulations is there should
be 100 universal background checks even
for personal transactions there should
be no gun show loophole
there should be significant actual
penalties enforced many of which are
already on the books but are rarely
enforced for going around the
regulations that exist there should be
mandatory gun insurance the way that we
have it with vehicles in most states
not all but in most states you're
required to have insurance if you have a
vehicle you're required to complete a
course and take a test etc i think that
that should also be the case with guns
there should be re-licensing
um over time and i think it's perfectly
reasonable to put limits on
um
you know uh
uh amu clip capacity for example all of
those things seem reasonable to me but
yeah magazine capacity
it's got to be the most pragmatic and
reasonable take i've heard unlike this
issue from a democrat it's really good
i'm not a democrat
oh really [ __ ] yeah no 100 agree that's
a really solid take all right well thank
you
let's get on the magazine restrictions
but i can completely get behind
everything else
yeah i mean it's like it it's the second
we need to start from the premise of
what's real and like the second
amendment exists
and
democrats running on
changing the second amendment
eliminating it
seems like a recipe for political
disaster
yeah
yeah i think yeah from i guess you could
use the term optics from an optics point
of view it's a good move
all right yeah i mean and listen the
things i'm mentioning
are so non-controversial in most of the
world but republicans would still oppose
all of them
yeah
anyway it's great getting on talking to
you and i'm glad we were able to
surprisingly have it come to
come to like a really good
i guess
that was a really good take i wasn't
expecting that
well thank you i'm glad i was able to uh
satisfy your desire for a good take
thanks see me thank you hey thank you
ranger
uh so speaking of takes
so anime king
um his question is what is your most out
there slash hot take right so we just
heard a reasonable one what do you think
your most controversial take would be i
have no idea that would be for someone
else to tell me i have no clue uh man i
was my most controversial or hot tick
i don't know
it's really for someone else to say
okay
um it's pretty pretty uh fair answer mr
enemy king uh next question is gonna be
from jumpscare24
that question is what are your thoughts
on canada's response to the trucker's
protest specifically referring to the
seizing of financial assets
yeah um so
when when the emergency i i don't
remember exactly what it's called in
canada the emergency
powers act or emergency measure i don't
remember the name of it when it was
enacted
uh there was a ton a ton
of either
out of ignorance or out of bad faith
misinterpretation of what it did and
didn't do
and the main thing i took issue with was
as often as the case
the idea that this was just the
beginning of some slippery slope towards
total authoritarianism police state or
whatever and then like after a couple
weeks trudeau uh cancelled it
and um so i to be totally frank i don't
know enough about the financial
regulation piece but i know that that
talking point you just gave me was
widely disputed i i just did not follow
the specifics of what it did from a
banking standpoint in canada closely
enough to be able to say
uh definitively what my opinion on that
piece is but i was very skeptical of the
idea that this was trudeau
starting down a path of tyranny and
indeed after a couple weeks he canceled
it and things are back to normal
okay well i mean speaking of uh seizing
financial assets um conoco's question
is do you think it's fair for financial
organizations like paypal visa and
mastercard to stop businesses in russia
and i'm sorry to stop business in russia
and lock russian citizens out of
accessing their funds especially
russians who make a living through the
internet like like youtubers and twitch
streamers do i think it's fair
if fair in what sense or do i think it's
legal or do i think it's moral what do
you mean by fair
uh i think i think chronicle means uh
moral i i guess he'd say and guys if
there were any like follow-ups here to
the questions that you're asking through
text um i i can only interpret them so
much so
if you want to clarify something just
you know ping me and let me know so
listen i mean here here's my view here's
my view
life is not fair
uh and there are tons of people
individuals in russia who don't agree
with what's going on
and they are being hurt
by what some of these companies are
doing and they are being hurt by the
sanctions there's no way uh to to get
around that and so at the individual
level that's not fair in other words if
some individual content creator in
russia
does tech reviews and doesn't agree with
what putin did and now that individual
is um you know locked out of youtube
revenue
it's not fair at a personal level
it is absolutely something that these
companies can do they can choose to do
business wherever they want and for
whatever reason they do or or don't want
to
uh and the whole point here is that they
believe either number one
they'll get good pr from doing it which
is you know kind of a cynical
self-centered view and they may be right
or number two they believe that they are
participating in
what they believe to be
the right thing to do by
trying to hinder
russia's invasion of ukraine so is it
fair to the individuals absolutely not
uh but
it's it's
you know this is what
as a as a number of governments have
said we can do short of starting to bomb
russia
uh to try to get them to back off and
whether it serves the greater good or
not everybody's got to kind of draw that
line where they see fit
okay and uh conical if you have any
follow-ups to that you can either come
into the voice chat and speak them
directly or just ping me with a
follow-up and text chat
um
thank you david our next question is
from fipto fipto whatever you're ready
mister
hello can you hear me yes i can
okay uh yeah so i i just had some
questions about some takes that you've
had over the past i guess
year year and a half maybe okay um over
two two stories
uh so so
of course the first one cal written
house and the second one would be on
george floyd like kind of just a pic
pick of your brain on the george floyd
instance because i've advocated
um
well one contention with his death over
another and i just want to pick at your
brain and see what you believe in that
instance
but on the kyle rittenhouse case
um
well judging from some of the takes that
you've had i
to be honest i don't remember them
outright completely um
but does it kind of disenchant you of
you know the media and uh
you know how far they can go to actually
slander a person to take a large
populace of people and make them think
one way even though it's the overt uh
falsehood of something
i don't know what you're talking about
um so on written house uh
i mean i guess
there were some claims that he was a
white supremacist that didn't seem based
in evidence so that was that was bad
that was wrong
but um
yeah i don't know you're saying you
don't remember the takes but so
is there a specific question for me i
guess
uh
well i mean i guess it's just kind of um
pick out your brain kind of on uh
i guess
how trusting outright people can be of
the media now because
um previously i guess people could just
take a news article and argue and
advocate that that news article is
correct but
now we have to
kind of think okay this news article
could be correct but we're not
completely sure
and we shouldn't jump to any conclusions
because of it um
one thing i noted to my father-in-law he
watches msnbc and i had to show him an
image of msnbc saying that cal
rittenhouse shot three black men
now
that that's outright false as everybody
could witness whoever watched the court
cases
um
and
i mean
i guess the question is this is kind of
you know disenchant you of what
common news outlets people would
reference as you know arbiters of truce
um does that kind of disenchant you to
i guess their uh authoritative
uh
fact checking in a sense it doesn't
really do anything to me because i feel
like i had a pretty
uh realistic understanding of media
literacy and how media operates before
that so for me
what i try to do is to critically
analyze
primary sources and so to really look at
first of all is what i'm looking at an
opinion piece or is it a rewrite of a
primary source or is it the primary
source so i kind of start with that this
is sort of really about basic media
literacy the written house case
no more than anything else in particular
uh
made me rethink that i mean i think
one of the issues is you're when you
refer to the media that's really not one
thing like are we talking about
newspaper articles that cite sources are
we talking about some febrile screed
from tucker carlson or like you know
what i mean even referring to the
established media
sorry what was that like like people
people who've been around to the point
of when the government paid for them to
be you know co-opted with them what do
you mean when the government paid who to
be co-opted
like old generation media like
organizations that have been here for
probably two decades or more so like fox
news
oh yeah yeah even them even though yeah
and so what do you mean the government
paid them to be co-opted by them
well so there were some there were some
things that i could look back in the
past where
um
well news articles would would go we
wouldn't want to they wouldn't want to
jump the gun
and they would kind of cite whatever the
white house officials would say the cia
officials would say hold on white house
or cia what do you what's a story what's
an example story where that
where did that happen
okay so um well you could you could say
um well i guess everybody could cite uh
iraq
okay
so on iraq on iraq the bush
administration made a case for war with
iraq
that was based on bad intelligence
yeah okay
and so therefore what so that was that
was 20 years ago and so then so
then what
or
honestly just on my driving
but uh
yeah i'd ask more in the
msnbc case you know where they say that
he shot where kylo ren has shot three
black men and msnbc uh they've
they're kind of like
they're really well known
they're one of the more popular meters
media sources people subscribe to
okay
i i i have to tell you i don't know
where this is going but people should
understand number one are they analyzing
a primary source or not
number two yeah what are the biases of
the source i am looking at
number three
uh
[Music]
you know this is basically it's basic
media literacy we should start teaching
it when kids are ten
we don't and it's a real problem in this
country
yeah yeah well i don't think yeah i i
don't think people want to be as
involved into politics as
um
as they feel that they should be now
people don't want to be as involved in
the politics
as they feel that they should be now
i don't know i don't know about that i
don't know what that means i mean you
have tons of independents waking up now
and what are they waking up to
uh
well i think in the past election well
of course you have some faulty some
people with that sorry what you had what
you had fall city what did you have
yeah i'm saying people that believed in
the false notions of q anon or people
that followed donald trump um i see the
falsities of
like in in certain instances where
people just kind of awakened
um to a different reality and everybody
seems kind of politically activated
oh okay so people do want to be polite
yeah that's what i mean they okay all
right
well yeah well previously they didn't
most people would have said that they
don't want to have anything to do with
politics but now they're looking around
going
um
things are
they're kind of feeling like they're
being the rug's been swept out of under
them you know by who
by individuals which but who which
individuals so one individual i would
say
is um especially
so in canada um do you know who mr
sunshine baby is he's been covering a
lot of the protests
no
okay um on youtube he grew up he
actually blew up on youtube so
about 200 he got about 200 000
subscribers in about uh five to ten days
is
uh because he's just been covering
what the canadian news has been saying
what trudeau's been saying covering the
protests um yeah all of that and
yeah
he kind of he he gave his own story too
about how
you know specifically
he doesn't want anything to do with
politics yeah but he's looking left and
right and seeing what the canadian
government's doing and saying okay well
this is wrong i feel like i need to step
up to the plate now because
you know it used to be you people used
to feel like the government is
you know kind of uh i wouldn't want to
say daddy but you know that
the daycare worker who would take care
of the things that you wouldn't think
about
so in other words
canadian youtuber mr baby is one of the
individuals you cited who pulled the rug
out from under american independence is
that my understanding that correctly no
no no no
wait what uh no no no uh he's he's feel
he feels that the canadian government
pulled the ruck out of under him because
you know i thought you said it was
independence that did why not well
listen you've really said it all these
questions too hard oh no yeah okay i'm
not i'm not trying to i'm not trying to
trip you up or anything oh no i'm not
worried about that don't worry about
that you're you're doing good okay all
right good well listen it's been a
pleasure speaking with you
okay i i do have one more question oh
okay
okay yeah i don't i don't take up too
much time but uh george floyd yeah so
um with the recent stats and
oh and fentanyl
nurses and deaths uh of people
uh does that kind of enlighten you maybe
a little bit on
how dangerous this drug actually is
i don't know what that has to do with
george floyd because the medical experts
who testified in the case said that that
that was not a factor in his death if i
recall correctly
well
the medical examiner i believe before
the they saw the video they had
testified that if they had not seen the
video that they would have thought he
died from an
okay
overdose
don't i don't remember that being
testimonial detected in his body listen
fentanyl is a problem i'm against
fentanyl people when it's not properly
uh administered and uh yeah fentanyl can
be bad
yeah i i don't know if you know the
about the stat of uh
18 to 45 year olds actually killed the
most 18 to 14 year old
last year
um even more than kobe did yeah hey
listen i think we gotta run but i'm
curious who did you vote for in 2020
definitely donald trump you voted for
trump okay yeah that i'm not surprised
to hear that
oh why is that
i'm just not surprised
we do have a lot of people yeah let's go
let's keep going but that was very
interesting phone call no no that's
that's fine
okay thank you thank you uh our next
question is gonna be from
a unix root colonel please clip that for
my team you gotta clip that okay my
team's gonna clip that
okay thank you her question is um how
can educational reforms be introduced in
schools like media and scientific
literacy like you know you just
expressed a little bit ago yeah um
when we have uh conservatives calling
education reform liberal indoctrination
right so here's the thing you know
earlier we had a really good question
about how the right is just much better
at funding these groups like turning
point usa they do cpac they have unity
they activate you know it's like kids
got to put masks on next thing you know
you've got every crazy parent at these
school board meetings completely losing
their mind and making it impossible to
do anything
a lot of education policy most education
policy is basically local municipality
and state
and so the left needs to really activate
and start demanding
basic media literacy and critical
thinking be taught
everywhere starting in fifth grade when
they go and they say we don't want masks
at the school board meetings
the left needs to do that ten times over
but saying we want critical thinking and
we want media literacy if you start that
in a serious way when kids are 10
a lot of this entire problem including
that last phone call we had it would all
take care of itself
but we've got to activate we we've got
to be going to the school board meetings
we've got to be demanding the curriculum
changes
okay awesome
uh next question is going to be from uh
solomon question is
what are your opinions on what's going
on between china and taiwan and should
america and the west try to build up and
increase their naval presence in the
taiwanese strait in the hopes of
deterring possible future chinese
invasion of taiwan yeah so i think that
uh it would be incredibly you know
the types of interventionist ideals that
i oppose
would um
because i'm opposed to that me as the
guy sitting in the u.s
would it would not be appropriate for me
to say yeah go and stuff the seas full
of american you know navy vessels now
absent those requests uh uh fro from
coming from from those in the area
i said at the very beginning of the
russian invasion of ukraine
that this
may well be an opportunity that peaks
the interest of china
to pay very close attention to and see
what does russia get away with in
ukraine to then think about well what
might we be able to get away with in
taiwan and we've seen some encroachments
on airspace over the last few weeks so i
think it would be naive to think china's
not thinking really hard about what can
we get away with um but i think they're
probably
going to wait a little longer to see how
russia eu ukraine plays out but i think
there's no question that they have those
ambitions 100 percent
awesome okay uh so speaking of ambitions
uh next question is from her
diablos i can't say that word um mr mr
hurry you are unmuted going are you
ready
uh yeah hello thank you my pleasure i'm
from germany
it's her depots
okay
yeah thank you for um yeah letting me
ask my question my pleasure um so my
question is uh as the ukraine crisis is
going on do you think more european
countries like austria sweden or finland
are going to join the nato
um i i don't know i mean that that
process uh takes wait hold on a second
which which countries did you mention
let me look up the current list of nato
members um austria sweden and finland
austria sweden and finland
ah finland finland's an interesting one
because of its proximity to russia and i
might consider that in a slightly
different category because there's some
strategic
relevance to finland
um
i don't know i mean the the process of
joining nato is not a short process and
so
even if there are new nato members in
reaction to what's happening right now
in ukraine i don't think we're going to
see that immediately i think there's
going to be much more immediate
decisions to be made like for example do
nato troops get sent in to intervene do
any of the countries that said we're not
going to send troops like the u.s change
their mind and say we're going to send
troops those questions to me seem much
more timely than whether there will be
new nato members because that's a sort
of a slow process but i don't know the
answer ultimately i don't know
okay
yeah because i've i've heard about um
like
uh questions where where the like 60 of
the uh us people
um in sweden
uh wanted to join nato
and that's why the politician uh
politics
uh are talking about it right now
yeah i just don't think that uh i mean
there's a lot that has to be sorted out
first i think before new nato membership
for like for example sweden is really
seriously discussed so i think it's sort
of like something for down down down the
road i don't see it as immediately
relevant to the conflict
okay thank you uh good night from
germany thank you good night
good night
uh next question is gonna be from
um brussels injury that question is
back in 2019 trump trump blocked the
appointment of new judges to the wto
appellate body a major blow to
multilateralism
more importantly biden has not reversed
the ban
given biden's commitment to
international organizations and
liberalism
why hasn't this intrigue this issue been
addressed by the administration i just
don't really think biden cares i mean
here's the thing you know with a lot of
these things
you you often have to take a a position
you often have to take a position um
when you're campaigning for something
and the prototype for the epitome of
this to me is the student loan thing
where
biden was put essentially pushed into
saying he'd consider
um
for giving some student loans
and i never thought biden really cared
about that and now people are saying why
hasn't biden forgiven student loans and
the answer is because i don't think he
really cares about that now i there's
actually some detail with the student
loans thing which is biden actually has
forgiven more dollars in student loans
than any other president but it was
specifically people who were essentially
scammed by for-profit schools the
details don't matter but the whole thing
was i don't think he really cares with
everything that's going on right now
uh and biden suffering from low approval
and needing some major accomplishment
uh you know nominations to the wwto
appellate corps it i just don't think
it's on his radar uh and and it's it's
it's kind of depressing to just see it
that way but i just don't think he
really cares
okay
um
yeah so basically bigger fish fish to
fry yeah basically yeah
um and speaking of one of those big fish
um
next question um is going to be from
abeard19 that question is
do you believe the rising gas prices
will accelerate the west development of
renewable energy
well i tweeted about this earlier
actually and i said
obviously it takes time to transition
off of gas we can't just be like oh
there's a crisis with oil let's switch
to electric cars tomorrow obviously we
can't do that but it should really be
making us think of the fact that we've
failed to
quickly enough move away from fossil
fuels over the last 10 years already so
i hope
that this really accelerates the move
away from gas-powered vehicles and home
oil heating etc but unfortunately i
worry that it won't because there's
still so much money in fossil fuels
there's still so much geopolitics that's
based almost exclusively around the the
oil trade so yeah any any logical person
would say wow this is like another
reminder that we could be
far less reliant on burning these
substances
but um we seem to have a complete
quagmire when it comes to really getting
off of this stuff and financial
incentives are ninety percent of the
reason why
yeah i honestly i i um i felt my gasket
like like once a week uh maybe
and i when i went out uh it was like
almost six dollars a gallon and i can't
imagine if i were in the financial
position that i was in
10 12 years ago right now when i started
my business
um i can't imagine how i would have like
survived yeah right how i would have
gotten around so i i i feel so bad for
people now young people people who are
already barely scraping by yep suddenly
yeah we we need to start looking at
other options yeah and you know there's
times when in the past gas has gone up
15 cents a gallon and it's like listen
for 99 of people they don't drive enough
for that to make a substantive
difference in their monthly budget they
just don't
we're now talking about something very
different we're at 4
423 a gallon or 419 a gallon or
something like that average and it looks
like it could be going to 520. you're
now really talking about a change that
can in fact impact people's monthly
budget in addition because trucks will
be paying more for fuel it's going to
start impacting the cost of a lot of
household items and uh no this is this
is serious
yeah i mean i just kind of hit on this
again because i i
i remember digging around in my seats
right for change right to find 25 cents
to put it put in the gas tank right um
and and i imagine that there are lots of
people out there in a similar position
so yeah if you guys are listening you
would you please we we really need to
push on this you know yep write letters
do whatever you can because it's it's
desperate for a lot of these people
um okay my little squeal is over next
question is gonna be from uh philippo
fish
uh philip as soon as i find you on this
list you're gonna be muted and
go for it whenever you're ready
hi can you hear me yes i can
hey
watch the show quite a bit um
thank you do you see the us as actually
backsliding from democracy at this point
and
moving towards some sort of
ungovernability and if so if you do see
that what is the meaningful steps that
we as individuals can take to avert this
disaster so i st so
two parts the there has been a backslide
in the united states in terms of uh
democracy there's no doubt about it
there's a number of different reports a
number of different measures and indices
that are used and the u.s has been
backsliding uh for sure
i still remain cautiously optimistic
and you know i might end up eating my
hat in 10 years i still remain
cautiously optimistic that the united
states is not going to become this
authoritarian dystopia
um but there's no question that a
certain level of authoritarianism a
certain level of attacks on i mean
listen trump straight up
would kick people out from the press
room when he didn't like them said the
media is the enemy of the people called
reporting he didn't like fake news
expected the supreme court and local
courts to just do what he wants because
that's what he wants these are really
big infringements upon press freedom and
judicial freedom it's a really crazy
thing he would say don't the things
you're hearing and seeing you can't
believe them you know real really
dystopian stuff
um some of it sort of like out in 1984
some of it out of brave new world by
aldous huxley so yes the u.s has been
backsliding but
uh i remain cautiously optimistic that
it's not going to become uh an
authoritarian dictatorship
do you see countries like india brazil
or even the philippines as kind of
models of the intermediary steps between
u.s now and uh you know some sort of
dystopian future
i i mean
i see them as in between in many ways i
hope that it never actually is is what
what takes place but yeah i mean you can
look at these nationalist authoritarian
movements in a lot of different places
to get a sense of the ideology and to be
perfectly frank i did a segment last
week about why so many republicans love
putin a lot of the stuff that the trump
bites would like to see you already see
in russia with putin and that's pretty
scary
great thanks and that's
my question thank you i appreciate it
thank you mr fish
uh next questions from uh
magma the question is in light of the
current situation in e in the eu and
ukraine do you think it would be
sensible
to punish russian users on discord and i
assume that means restrict their access
to discord
oh man i mean with all i guess the point
is to what end right what it what is the
point and so like mcdonald's is
temporarily shutting down some uh some
some locations i guess they call them
restaurants well i can i can give you um
a reason right uh that they might this
might be like something to consider sure
um there are
servers communities on discord that um
exist solely to peddle russian
propaganda for example
right so
um and and i'm assuming magma when he
when he asked this question was was
thinking of those i hope i i hope he
doesn't mean just you know banning
russian users for no reason my instinct
on that would be
uh that it's sort of like when reddit
banned the donald subreddit they unless
in if you have individual users
spreading disinformation you can ban
them if you have a particular channel or
server that is spreading disinformation
i have no problem with that i don't know
that just a blanket ban on all russian
users is the way to go
okay next question is gonna be from uh
dara some nebulon
if i pronounce that correctly love it uh
you are unmated whenever you're ready
hello can you hear me yes i can
yeah uh the name was right thank
you have a question
romney recently on a show
you said something to the extent that
him and another politician politician
if you had to choose mitt romney would
be your choice as he made a principle
stand against trump
and so on
i remember when i was young and
candidate against barack obama and me
and my classmates very
well we could say now had a trumpian
moment um about him
um
[Music]
to the extent that uh he's vile
what i i apologize for interrupting i'm
losing every third word i heard you say
something about romney when i i know
that you referred to when i talked about
romney versus mansion and now you're
talking about obama versus someone else
um no
when mitt romney
was on
in running against barack obama ah obama
yes um
in my class i was 14 at the time i think
um
we were
very um
aghast that that would be a possibility
having someone like him as a president
him being mitt romney or him being obama
uh no uh mitt romney okay
we lost obama um
do you see a way to
republicans going back to
someone like
mitt romney or even more
having a principles that they stand for
yes if not viable anymore if trumpism if
trumpism is soundly defeated
and they become convinced that it wasn't
voter fraud
it wasn't you know whatever that they
lost they lost because trumpism is a
disaster for them if they really lose
then
i believe they would go back to
something like mitt romney but if they
keep winning or plausibly winning
um then they are going to they seem
determined to stick with trumpist stuff
for the time being
okay
very think uh thank you very much thank
you sorry for the long-winded talk oh no
problem thank you
uh next question is going to be from
bree bree asks
david do you believe that american
society is beginning to question pride
in our own nation more
or less due to recent elections and
events uh and do you believe that
internal distress of the u.s uh
government is growing
those are really empiric they're just
polling questions i don't have the
polling in front of me so it's just me
speculating you know it's uh
that's a question to which there is an
answer and we know that since trump left
and biden came in
the opinion of the u.s globally has
improved like that we know empirically
no matter what don jr says and these are
empirical questions i just don't have
the data in front of me i'll give you my
personal take which is for me when i
think about patriotism i think about
things like
what good is my country doing around the
world
or
how does the country
does the country take pride in making
sure everybody even the least among us
as the phrase is
have a basic acceptable standard of
those are the things i think about not
like military might and and nationalism
and stuff like that and so for me i'm
very comfortable being critical of uh of
of what the united states does when it
doesn't meet my ideals but as to whether
people in general are more comfortable
saying this type of thing i think you've
just got to look at polling and i don't
have the polling data in front of me
okay thank you
uh our next question is from arthur
wellesley um and arthur you are
where are you on this list
uh i'm gonna circle back to you because
okay i can't find him
um so while we're waiting for arthur to
pop up uh the next question is gonna be
from um
uh gabriella m gabriella whenever you're
ready
hi can you hear me yes
uh i wanted to know if you believe that
companies such as mcdonald's pulling out
of russia could have negative impacts on
younger generations and perhaps their
perception
of
basically countries outside of the west
like is this going to be a new cold war
feel for specifically younger people
uh you know mcdonald's is temporarily
closing a few stores or restaurants or
factories whatever they call them um
and i think that it's it's mostly for
optics i have a hard time imagining that
that decision by mcdonald's is going to
significantly foment a new cold war i i
think if there was a bigger you know
what
if we're talking about extended
sanctions
and
netflix cutting off russia
mcdonald stays close you know if if you
see this as a long-term uh and
ubiquitous thing i think there'd be more
to talk about but quite frankly i think
mcdonald's is just doing what they think
will look good in the immediate and it's
going to be very temporary
okay i just remember a speech actually
from obama uh
when he was in vietnam and he spoke
about the
necessity for the jcpoa with iran and
opening back up to vietnam because young
people
weren't to blame for an authoritarian
that in many chances came into power
before they were even born yeah i agree
with that and i think you could even
apply that to you could apply that to
cuba as well where what's the the cuban
embargo doesn't make any sense i think
what's happening acutely right now in
this short period of time with russia
and ukraine is a little bit different
now if it lasts 20 years then i'm going
to feel differently about it
of course yeah of course i just hope
that the sanctions remain
as narrow on the people in charge as
possible to not have unnecessary
uh consequences for
young
city people who are
you know
i mean because really sanctions there's
not a lot of evidence that they do a lot
to get people to
uh
protest and things like that we have
iran cuba venezuela many cases that
actually point to the contrary that
rallying around the flag is
a huge possibility
i i don't disagree with you
thank you for taking me thank you
awesome okay next person is going to be
uh arthur wesley again or wellesley i
found him this time arthur uh whenever
you're ready mister
arthur
oh now somebody's been working that's
unfortunate please proceed governor okay
arthur um
we'll circle back to you one more time
in a little bit uh but if
if not i'm just going to read out your
question
so next question is therefore going to
be from conical the question is
would you support decriminalizing all
drugs to help end the war on drugs yes i
support decriminalizing all drugs and
treating them as a public health issue
where i stop short for now and this is
only because i've not
heard a good case made i don't know
about
legalizing recreationally things like
heroin and cocaine i just i've not
seen a really good case made for that
but on decriminalization absolutely
now um as part of that would you before
like
it's my understanding of the way that uh
portugal did this was they
decriminalized the the use of these
things and i think possession but if you
were selling um these drugs that was so
like a criminal act right
is that the kind of decrimination i'm
sorry decriminalization you're talking
about it depends on which drugs i think
that there there are drugs where i don't
you know we you you really should
legalize and regulate
um but in term if we're strictly
speaking about decriminalization i think
you need to take it on a drug by drug uh
i i think that
selling and and produ if you do like
let's take cannabis for example if you
decriminalize cannabis i'm thinking you
decriminalize use and you decriminalize
possession
and you decriminalize
growing it in your backyard
and then
on mass dealing i think you have to
think about the best way to to go
forward
if you decriminalize
cocaine i don't know that you
decriminalize the dealing uh man it's
complicated though i i have to think
more about that maybe you do i i want to
think about that a little more
okay
um so we're going to try arthur one more
time please arthur fingers crossed
uh go for it hello uh perfect there you
are right uh i wanted to ask why do you
think right-wing people uh end up
right-wing and left-wing people
left-wing like is it is it a lack of
education on issues is it uh different
core values is it what people are
socialized into um yeah so there's a lot
of there's a lot of studies about this
and there's not really one answer so
first and foremost there's some work
that suggests that
i i always hesitate to say that the
brains of conservatives and liberals are
different but to some degree
there's a different uh jonathan height
has written about this there are
different sensibilities to for example
disgust and
other uh uh sort of um uh
mechanisms uh fear centers in the brain
etc so this is this is like one part of
it there's a cultural piece which is
people are statistically more likely to
have the politics that their parents
have and that they grew up around so you
know like mississippi continues to have
more conservatives than liberals and
part of it is that conservative parents
continue to have children and
statistically they're more likely to be
conservative so so i think that's a
factor as well there's not one answer to
this
hello
yeah no okay i mean i just wanted to get
your thoughts also yeah
okay
uh thank you right there our next
question is going to be from
han faizy um i'm sorry if i didn't
pronounce it correctly uh whenever
you're ready
uh hi can you hear me yes i can and uh
moderation team just as a heads up i'm
sort of getting to the end of my time so
maybe we'll just do a couple more sure
okay okay so like yeah my question is
about like what you're saying i'll just
read it out uh given that gerrymandering
is a serious problem that undermines the
democratic process what do you think
about
acceleration about gerrymandering
if democrats strategically gerrymandered
some state to make the wrong more
obvious
might they be able to force the hand of
the supreme court i'm sort of worried
that otherwise the right-leaning supreme
court will not act and gerrymandering
will go on indefinitely that's a really
interesting question so the idea is
democrats instead of trying to read
gerrymander in their favor favor when
they're able to
they just make
the gerrymandering even more overtly
right wing so that the supreme court
would have no choice but to act
yeah it could be either way in just to
make the wrong of gerrymandering more
obvious so that the supreme court would
have to do something where it would just
be so explicit um that like
the threat to democracy would be more
obvious i hesitate to suggest that
that's a good idea
because it's already so damn obvious i
mean look up the shape of dan crenshaw's
district in texas
and i have a hard time believing as
obvious as it is now that if it's even
more obvious that all of a sudden the
supreme court's going to change it and
unfortunately in the interim
it's going to lead to even more lopsided
results for republicans so i think that
that's a dangerous idea i mean i think
it's super interesting to talk about but
i think it's dangerous
all right thank you my pleasure
okay so um we're gonna do two more we're
gonna be respectful of david's time uh
arab
what's your name arab uh love russia i
think your name is uh you're next
whenever you're ready sir yes so like i
noticed that a lot of your content is
based on like trump january 6 like
marjorie taylor green i'm wondering like
why don't you focus on like real
politics instead of like like this weird
like trump stuff
okay what's a topic you'd like me to
cover
uh you should cover like the fight for
medicare for all the fight for labor
instead of like oh trumpers said this or
like that anti-vaxxers scream in a
walmart
well we cover all of those i do know
exactly what you're saying i appreciate
the question um we do cover all of those
things and uh i absolutely love the
feedback
all right well let me give you a
challenge before i go can you talk can
you not make a video about trump for
like one week just one week
what's the point of the challenge
just to see if you can do it just to see
if you cannot talk about trump for a
week and what would that what would that
prove
i don't know i mean if you look at your
channel every single day it's like trump
investigation or january 6 committee
it's like why don't you just do one week
where it's like i'm not going to talk
about trump i'm going to restrain from
trump's stuff and i'm gonna go to other
things okay and and if i do that then
then what would we prove or achieve
uh like the whole politics world is
gonna like change everything's gonna
change just based on my youtube channel
yeah wow that's really some i should
think i didn't that's that's a lot of
power i mean when you think about it
that way that's really a lot of power
yeah i i
i gotta say i sincerely regret uh you've
been one of the last questions
um but thank you
if you're ready go for it
hi
here i'm just gonna step up i'll be
right back i'm sorry i'm getting my
nails done um i just wanted hold on a
second you're at a nail salon right now
yeah and i feel bad they're picking up
my color for me and i totally just left
them i'm sorry we went back one second
oh my god um what is that like acrylic
or something
um yeah i'm getting my tips redone
actually sorry you're getting what
redone
my tips oh my god oh my god okay holy
[ __ ] that's acrylic but they're gel
right yes you don't want them to chip
right like no chips i got it anyways
okay hey okay first comment real quick
i'm fine okay i'm dina first comment
your voice is way deeper on these calls
like on your youtube channel i don't
know why is that weird okay second
comment i kind of want to pick your
brain about hate speech right because
okay so i feel like i'm kind of like a
moral fear like okay so like i'm not a
moral relative when it comes to hate
speech right because i still think those
objective things when it comes to like
something should not be crossed when it
comes to hate speech but like also i get
okay so like i'm palestinian so like i
get when it comes to a point where like
bds obviously is like totally slandered
in like american media was like oh it's
a tourist organization almost bs right
but also there's some things that
literally just should not be crossed in
i think like
um a civil speech right so i just
segmented your view and like what you
perceive as hate speech and like if you
do think that any speech should be
allowed like if you're like a free
speech like absolutist you know what i
mean
i am not wow that's a lot there you're
you're shot out of a cannon today i have
to say oh no absolutely no this is how i
totally talk i'm actually talking really
slow right now because i don't want
people here to think like i'm on crack
okay you know what i mean with love and
peace sorry okay just go up you're
talking slow right now you're saying
yeah absolutely oh well good listen um i
am
close to a free speech absolutist now
hold on a second are you at in what
context are you just saying like on
twitter or what or if i had my own
platform or what do you or the
government what do you mean
okay so like
okay so i get the whole platform debates
like oh i own twitter so i could say
that's right but when i people say that
i reply twitter is definitely now public
space to be honest right but okay let's
just do the government context because
like if we went into the whole twitter
debate that'll be a whole other
conversation right so we'll just do
government debates right now right um
like if we're in a public space like
debating on protesting right
yeah how free should it be right because
like um i know there's this whole like
content versus
time and space but like the government
can obviously use time and space even
when they just want to do content just
to be like oh we just we're just we're
just putting the we're just putting a uh
like we're just putting a curfew because
you know we want to expect the public
but it's actually because they want to
you know limit the all on protests right
time and space that's interesting now
are you talking
metaphysically like are we talking about
the government could even bend space
time to its advantage no no no no i'm
talking about like you know how they
could do curfew was um like um if you're
talking about it like if you're taking
it to court and stuff you can be like oh
my god i know you're doing i sound
stupid you know what i mean like curfew
was right um because after almost once
in two so like during the
the protest that whole that led to the
like what says his name or whatever his
name is um
you know what i'm talking about right
are you talking about
what
were are you talking about
kyle rittenhouse
yeah but the reason why i called in
household thing was they shouldn't have
been out in the first place because
there was curfew laws and they put the
curfews laws
because of they were saying oh they want
the safety of the public but really if
you're going to talk about the court
they're actually doing it because of the
alarm that goes the content not the time
um reasoning you know what i mean i i
actually don't know where you mean where
is your accent from are you are you from
new york
no it's from wisconsin
with quansen i've i that's a very
unusual accent
no like do you want to okay like oh okay
so i just took i took a class on this
that's why i know because i was going to
be a lawyer and how to come into
breakdown right so i took an undergrad
class about this right um like so the
reasoning if you took us to court right
there's two like um there's like strict
perception of it and then there's like
non-strip perception of or like whatever
i'm like what i'm sure i know sometimes
i'm literally like this alone right now
um so like the time thing is like
we're going to um not allow protest
because of the timing versus we're not
going to protest because we don't like
the content of what you're protesting
right yeah a lot of times the government
says we're going to not allow it because
of the because the time because it's too
late and they use that a lot though when
it's the claim that they don't like
either but they can get away with it
because of the timing do you know what i
mean you're not from long island are you
serious i'm like what
but like i just wanted i want to pick a
brain about hate speech right
yes i i will go with you you want to
pick my brain about hate speech that
part i understand we've not gotten
anywhere further than that so
listen it sounds like a lot is going on
um i can't tell you how much i
appreciate the call i hope that the
manicure goes well what's a manicure
cost in wisconsin anyway okay oh my god
okay there were dramatically like
literally sixty dollars but it's only
forty dollars now because of them
because it's just a refill so it's fine
i'm sorry i what what is it how much
does it cost
it was 60 dollars for the original one
because i get a particular shape right i
get an almond with a round tip because i
hate square like square shaped vinegars
look like really abrasive and really
like masculine to me and i [ __ ] hate
it right so if you want something really
soft if you like have a girl in your
life
yeah
can you just tell me where you're really
from like
that
you're you're not from long island
no
well listen um thank you so much i can't
think of a better note on which we would
no i don't even know what the question
is you want to pick my brain about hate
speech i don't even know what that means
i mean i don't know oh my god okay i
mean i'm not gonna say thank you but
all right well
uh it's been a real pleasure thank you
so much
uh
good luck with your manicure um
okay yeah that was really something else
i mean that was interesting
um so we said that was the last question
um so david uh well first tell the
people in chat um i apologized if we
didn't get you and did my best to get in
as many people as possible um maybe
david will you know uh see to uh
gracious with his presence again at some
point i would love to i would love to on
the basis of the last call i'm willing
to come back any time
okay
oh you guys can then you guys can thank
scribbles for for making that happen
thank you um so yeah david will be in
touch with you to try to set that up
we really really really really
appreciate you coming on and i
personally really appreciate you coming
on um you were actually one of the
people that was um
pretty like instrumental right in my
like political awakening my my personal
political awakening wow [ __ ] years
ago um you were in my rotation of like
you know the youtube content creators
that i thought was like reasonable well
researched well uh well-informed uh
putting forward arguments tonight that i
thought were solid um and even when i
disagreed with you i i appreciated what
you had to say so
i i
sincerely appreciate you coming on well
thank you so much it's been a real
pleasure doing it
and uh for those of you who aren't aware
of where to find david i'm going to post
all of his links in the announcements
again he's currently streaming on twitch
um twitch.tv david pakman but you'll
find him on youtube he has a website he
has a i think uh uh
uh national like nationally syndicated
radio show i think it is a podcast
indeed it's all of it all of the above
yeah he's doing everything and and if
you guys want to be on here and not
sound like an idiot when you're speaking
to people listen to david
[Laughter]
i'll do a lot of the legwork for you and
he'll give you the he'll give you the
right opinion
um
david thanks again uh is there anything
anything you want to say before you head
off no i mean we're gonna be uh this has
been an incredibly uh ripe content
generation tool and i think over the
next week we're going to be pulling a
lot of the most interesting phone calls
and we'll be putting them on our youtube
channel and it's really been a uh a gold
mine quite frankly of what the kids
these days call
content okay
well hopefully hopefully enough there's
enough gold there to get you back in
here at some point it's gonna get me to
the end of the rainbow absolutely
okay all right thank you so much
everybody yup have a great day uh wow
wow and throughout that people might be
interested to know
i received endless any time we do this
people start direct messaging me and
calling me on uh
on discord like i'm gonna interrupt the
ama to just talk to them it's very very
weird wow okay so for our editing team
the calls we absolutely i think have to
do are
the wisconsin caller at the very end
um that one person that
went endlessly about
the independence had the rug pulled out
from under them
the guy who challenged me not to talk
about trump for a week
uh
right those are like the three wackiest
i think for sure the trump yeah the
trump guy
um
okay
very good all right guys that's gonna do
it for me today i'll be back with
another stream soon you know follow like
subscribe all these different things
don't cancel don't cancel everything but
canceling